there is a regenerative that's
happening right now in precision
billionaires know about it but the average
person doesn't what pushed me over the edge
recently is i had some experiences that really
hit me hard and the accident was so severe that
the prognosis was that my career was over
what would you say is available right now
that people would think is science fiction that
that doesn't exist but is actually happening that
people can do it's tactical right now here's
the coolest thing that's coming now kevin
ladies and gentlemen believe nation back for
the third time on our channel mr tony robbins
welcome back man thank you evan good to see
you man i like your studio it's gorgeous
it uh it's it's it's served me well it's gone
through a bunch of different phases but um yeah it
inspired one of the things i learned from you is
environment is critical so this inspires me every
day i walk into the office that's really cool
this is our third time we talked about money we've
talked about personal development those videos
have three million views on them wow crazy the
impact that it's having and the reach that it's
having but today we're talking about health you've
got a new book here it is i'm holding it up we got
life force in our hands and this is no joke man
this is 700 pages this is a serious book you can
build muscle just lifting it that's what i mean
why this book why is it so important to you well
you know i think you know me well enough my whole
life has been obsessed with how do you increase
the quality of life for people what are the tools
the strategies the breakthroughs that can make
that happen and there's only a few areas of life
that really matter it's your body clearly because
without energy and vitality and strength you have
nothing there's an old adage that says you know a
person with health has a million dreams a person
without it as one but then there's emotion
there's relationship there's finances right
there's you know your business or your career or
hopefully your mission and the spiritual side of
life and so i've always focused on this but what
pushed me over the edge recently is i had some
experiences that really hit me hard and one of
them was being an idiot going down chasing a 22
year old professional snowboarder and i'm not
a professional nor was i 22 and i discovered i
couldn't do the things this kid could do i found
out the hard way and the accident was so severe
that the prognosis was that my career was over
uh first i thought it broke my neck it was just
torn rotator cuffs but when i went into four
different doctors the thing they came across one
doctor set me down and said as bad as this is and
it was you know nine nine because it's nerve pain
he goes you got a much bigger problem he says
life as you know it is over this is literally
the guy's bedside matter i said clearly you
didn't go to my communications center all right
and i try to laugh about it he goes i'm this
is not a laughing matter he showed me my spine
and of course i've been in pain for more than 14
years and he said look he said you have extreme
spinal stenosis you know your life as you know
it's over there's no snowboarding there's no
running there's no jumping and you know what my
events are like it's you know i got people 15
000 people in a stadium for 12 hours a day three
or four days in a row people wouldn't sit for a
three-hour movie you can't do it by just talking
and so sure enough i you know i i took the gut hit
and then i got my head together and then i
called peter diamandis who's you know he's an
md from harvard but he's also a
rocket scientist a good friend of mine
and because i asked these doctors well what about
you know what's the prognosis they said well
you know you may not be able to lift your shoulder
arm above your shoulder um you know they may tear
again and four to six months of rehab and
i said you know i can't be one guy on stage
with my schedule it's just not possible and so
i said what about stem cells and you know i i
think you know i coach some of the greatest
of all time athletes in a variety of sports
and you know like for example cristiano ronaldo
he was supposed to be out three months he got stem
cells and he was done in two and a half weeks he's
back back playing so no no no they're not going to
do it not for something this severe so peter says
you need to talk to dr bob harar he was also a
co-author of my book now and bob is a neurosurgeon
but he's one of the 38 years ago helped to
discover stem cells and he said to me tony
look at your stage of life i was 53 at the time
he said you know your stem cells have dropped
off the cliff and he said so going in your own
stem cells might work for an elbow or a wrist but
not the complexity of what you have you need four
day old stem cells and i said i don't want field
tissue it goes no no not in a million years see
when babies are born we throw away most cases the
placenta and the cord now today a lot of families
take that and bob's the one who taught that and
created that whole system he said you need that
because it's the force of life and he said i'll
tell you where to go and he goes you can always
go back and do the surgery if it doesn't work but
i think you're going to find it well i did three
days of 20 minutes a day is all an iv in a shot
but they were cord stem cells four day old stem
cells the first day i just felt tired and slept
the second day i had a cytokine response i knew
what it was so it wasn't scary kind of shaking
and freezing for about 20 minutes just meant my
body really responded i went to sleep and evan you
wouldn't believe it i woke up the next day now is
my shoulder perfect and i've had the mri and so
forth since then no surgery no recovery time but
for the first time in 14 years i stood up with no
pain in my spine and so that made me an evangelist
i want to know everything about stem cells and
then i discovered it's not just stem cells there
is a regenerative that's happening in right now in
precision that very few people know about because
we live in the coveted world where everybody's
afraid and you know billionaires know about it
but the average person doesn't so just like i did
with money where i interviewed 50 of the smartest
people in the world ray dalio carl icahn warren
buffett etc and then simplified it i gave you 150
nobel laureates scientists and the best doctors in
the world to show you here are the little things
you can do right now that change your life in
various ways here's some of the newest technology
here's how you can prevent it and if you have
somebody in your family who has a or a challenge
here's the newest things that you can choose from
as opposed to the old approach of standard of care
which in some cases doesn't get great results
as many of us now so and i'm donating 100 of
the money just like my last three books this one
20 million meals are going to feeding america i'm
up to 850 million meals when i first met you i was
setting that goal about seven years ago so we're
almost to a billion meals uh and then the balance
is going for alzheimer's and heart and cancer
some of the top researchers in the world how many
times have you been told that your career is over
well i was told i was going to because i had a
tumor in my brain and my pituitary i still have
that tumor and i that was when i was 32 and i'm
62. so yes i've had a few of those but this one
was a little more scary i wouldn't say it was more
scary than the tumor but uh you know it certainly
seemed like the pain was not going to go away and
being able to find an answer has changed my life
completely i remember the voice box one where you
know you said you're never going to talk again you
can't do your thoughts anymore too that's right
a lot of the advice in the longevity field is
there's so much coming in the next 15 to 20
years that basically just don't like your advice
your job number one that was just don't
because so many amazing things are coming
yes what would you say is available right now
that people would think is science fiction that
that doesn't exist but is actually happening that
people can do it's tactical right now if you got
a or a challenge there are some things there's a
right now and it's covered by insurance and it's
in 100 hospitals incisionless brain you go why
would i want that well if you have a mother or
a father grandfather grandfather who's got
parkinson's you know i wouldn't watch this
uh person who couldn't walk across the room 15 of
them you know people understand shaking they can't
hold a glass they can't do anything they literally
go in with this extreme ultrasound it takes about
an hour to find the location that's controlling
the tremor they treated in 15 seconds as an
outpatient experience again 100 hospitals covered
by insurance this woman got off the table and
walked across the room perfectly and her glass
of water hadn't fully gently measured him when
she reached out her hand was solid she drank the
water i don't know if you ever seen anybody's
got those audio implants and then they hear for
the first time they start crying your eyes out
same reaction and that was two years ago the
first time i saw that i've been working this
project for three years two months ago maybe three
months ago now she was on a 50 mile bike ride
i mean just unbelievable there's a company
right now if people have osteoarthritis
and it's happening younger and younger people
unfortunately today for a variety of reasons based
on inflammation the way we eat and so forth
but osteoarthritis i mean it's unbelievably
painful there's no real great it's mostly you know
trying to use well there's a single this company
is in phase three trials so this is coming by they
believe the end of this year or next year so your
audience knows phase one is safety in the phase
two is effectiveness or efficacy base three is
efficacy at scale and then you're going to prove
so they're in the final phase soon they're going
to prove the end of this year beginning of spring
single and it fires off something called the wint
wnt pathway which is everything you're made of is
stem cells but the width pathway after you're born
is what directs it off send this many brain cells
that's the main hard cells they have found the
fountain of youth and the ability to either upload
it make it stronger or download it with cancer
where you want things to slow down not multiply
so much and they literally your body with one shot
regrows all your tendons in 11 months and it's
from your initial genome so it's like dolly the
sheep was old you got a brand new sheep you've
got 16 year old tenants even if you're 30 40 50
60 70 years old just mind-boggling then there's
the things that also that you should know about
that are breakthroughs in prevention because
for example cancer growing up i had this fear
of cancer early on i was i thought it was going to
young it was horrible and then i helped somebody
who's still alive today she was 40 she's not 80.
because it wasn't me i geared up i read everything
i said look if someone has stage 4 cancer and
they're supposed to thousands of people live
let's figure out what they do anyway she did it
she's alive today i write about it in the book
but it changed my mindset it changed my psychology
about things but today the reason people cancer is
because we find out too late in other words uh the
cancer society did a study with a hundred thousand
people and found if you have stage three or stage
four cancer 80 chance you i prefer 20 chance i
live and what do i do but their point is much
harder to turn around which is true if you do
it stage one or two you discover it there's an 80
to 99.9 percent chance that you're going to live
and so you want to catch it early well the
problem is we only have a few tests for cancers
you know mammograms for women let's say you
know testicle you've done for your colon and so
forth but most people where they is that cancers
that we don't have tests for so one of the great
things in this book is i tell the stories of the
heroes of the book the people have created these
unbelievable breakthroughs that'll blow your mind
and they went through 20 years ups and downs and
still made it through why because they all almost
everyone lost a husband a wife a daughter or a son
or someone and it made them go i'm not settling
for the standard care i'm gonna honor my child by
doing this so there's a new blood test that just
came out in the last six months it's called grail
it can find 50 different cancers before you have
any symptoms now the power of that is unbelievable
that with an mri which will go across the blood
brain barrier and you know what's going on in
your body and it's really inexpensive and the
guy that did it his wife of course they found
out too late and went through two years of this
and so he just geared up and found the answer but
it's so powerful we you know we have these sinners
these fountain life centers that i worked with dr
bill kaplan 12 hospitals he built and owned and
then he finally said i'm tired of care i want to
go into precision i want to go into regenerative
and so he's partnered with me of a bunch of
centers across the us and abu dhabi but he called
me and he says tony he said it's it's you can't
even believe this he said you got to see this guy
so we're talking about this man who just came in
his wife was you know she knew that what
we had she was pushing him he's like i had
my physical i did my blood i did my you know
urinalysis i'm fine we gave him the grail test
bladder cancer but the cool thing is it was
the early stage it was a 20 minute outpatient
procedure he's got no cancer i'll tell you
another one heart number one right men and women
but the cutting edge to know what's going on which
most people don't even get is the ct scan they
only go usually when they got pain or problems
a ct scan if you've ever seen one is extremely
hard to read they're looking for plaques in your
body that can you right well there's two different
types of blacks calcified and soft plaques soft
flex can break off and be the widow-maker right
turn you a heart you or give you a stroke but
calcified plaques are hard that means you're
actually healed so he said tony you know there's a
lot of the old technology up until again a little
less than six months ago it's really hard to tell
and so a lot happen they don't even need to happen
there's this new technology it's called ccta and
this technology uses ai and digitally opens up
all your arteries in your body that they film
through the ct searches with like a missile
inside and shows where the calcium is whether
it's you know soft or whether it's hardened
and if you're hard and you're fine but they can
predict a heart up to five years in advance and
tell you more importantly what to do to avoid it
so my partner called me and you know he's bill as
dr bill they call him his the most understated
guy this you know a lot of people are hypesters
when bill talks he talks real slow
and quiet we all lean in to listen
tony he said you know i have to tell you
it sounds exaggerated but i think we've
we've been exposed to one of the greatest
breakthroughs in cardiology in the last 10 years
like what is it bill you know my tempo is
different right he goes well he told me the whole
story i said okay i'm in i'm going to do this so
my father-in-law is with me and he just turned 80.
he's a self-made man built his own businesses very
much like you right just go get her make it happen
but his business was lumber he's a pretty strong
guy when you turn 80 people around you start
saying you should get your affairs in order and do
your will and stuff and i could just see the last
two or three years is energy shrinking so i said
dad look you're here with me i'm gonna go do this
test it's here in florida it's not far from here
just pop on the plane it's in western florida and
i said let's come with me i said we're both old
enough that we're gonna have some soft plaques but
we'll know where it is and they'll show us what to
do so he said okay i'm in i take my father-in-law
there he gets the test he has no soft flex his
entire body guys clean as a whistle at 80 years
old but changing him when he knew he was totally
fine was unbelievable i was better than i was five
years ago i was doing great but not as good as him
and so then we have this technique we've done for
some of the greatest athletes in the world it's
pretty extraordinary where when you have an injury
i'm sure you know connective tissue gets in there
and then lack of circulation and sometimes nerves
get trapped people go through big well now the
state of the art is they scan you with ultrasound
they can see exactly what's going on
so i have this ankle been a problem for
about 15 16 years you couldn't touch it even
like a massage it would shoot electricity at
my body because the nerves they see what the
problem is they put ammonia fluid in and it
opens up all the channels the fluid movements up
the oxygen goes up and the nerve pops in place it
took 15 minutes you can slap my side of my ankle
didn't feel anything it's perfect so i said to dad
he's there i said that you know he's having what
makes you feel old is not being able to move right
aches and pains and he has huge hip problems so i
said as long as you're here why don't you talk to
these ducks they scan and they find two locations
he needs simple for it takes 30 minutes and an
hour later he's walking smoothly silk for the
first time in 15 years right 20 years he's like
he gets on the plane with me this is one of
my favorite moments he crosses arms like this
and he goes you know tony these people talk
about living 110 120 i don't know about that
you know what my heart's perfect my hips perfect
i could live another 20 years you've only been
married to my daughter for 22 years that's like
another lifetime you know so there are tools not
just ray kurzweil is the person you're pretty much
coding who says take care of yourself today so you
make it to the time where this new technology
is here well he wrote that about 10 years ago
and ray wrote the introduction of my book by
the way raise a dear friend we're at the point
where some of those things are happening right now
but over the next three to seven years there are
going to be changes greater than have happened
in 200 years because as you know technology you
know doubles in its power every 18 month halves
in its cost well we don't usually see that in
but we're all code so i know you know i'm sure you
know about crispr and gene editing i mean we're
curing and everything cured there's a kid that
was on america's got talent who can now see for
the first time because of gene therapy so there
are so many extraordinary tools both to prevent
and there are so many tools to help you increase
and if you want to talk about more of them i've
talked too long we'll talk about those as well
oh those are great i mean i think of money master
the game you took an industry that people were
afraid of finances and we trusted the experts
and what you did with the book was demystified and
empower people to ask the right questions and pick
the right providers and it feels like you're doing
the same thing now just with health we trust the
experts to guide us to the right path but now
you're kind of arming people with the tools and
the right questions to ask so they can make better
decisions and have more accountability for their
own health is that a very true and not all experts
are equal as you well know whether it's finance or
health and so what i want to do is bring them the
best of the best with the track records there's
nothing in here this that's my opinion just like
the financial book everything is some of the best
people in the world you can judge for yourself
what you might want to do so you mentioned the
fountain life centers uh i went to the website
it looked like you had one in toronto which is my
hometown at least it said opening toronto yeah i
think they're just opening it so so i'm 41 as far
as we know i'm in great health uh you know losing
some hair maybe receding gum lines a bit but uh
apart from that you know passing my physicals if
i'm walking into fountain lifestyle number 41 male
what am i asking for what am i trying to get
well you might want to do you know say i want
to do an advanced physical because at 41 you're at
a beautiful tipping point you can continue to grow
and expand and if you make some mistakes or just
have things in your own dna you're unaware of your
own genetics that might need to be dealt with so
the best thing is to have the knowledge it's like
ignorance is not bliss ignorance is pain ignorance
can be problems so you can do that in about three
hours three and a half hours they do a full
body mri they do the grail test they'll do your
hormonal tests because at 40 your hormones will
start to shift at some point between 40 and 50.
and you don't want to wait till there's a problem
like i give an example you had a guy come in
um i think he was 44 45 remember his exact age
mid-40s and he's 36 pounds overweight clearly not
you he's you know lost his drive and you know we
said well if you looked at your hormones something
very simple right but most people like women
know about hormones but they think of hormone
replacement therapy which is like menopause well
before you get to replacement there's optimization
in the world we live and you can make tiny changes
and optimize your energy your strength and levels
most people don't dream about where you feel 10 or
15 years younger so the guy comes in he works out
like crazy can't lose weight listless all these
problems have have you done your hormones oh yeah
i've done more hormones well show us the test
so they sent us the test and you know he's at 2
25 on his testosterone well most doctors not going
to say you need replacement until you're like 175
but most men need seven to 900 or slightly higher
to feel human to feel alive to feel strong all we
did was make a small change not a giant of this of
testosterone and a guy lost 36 pounds in less than
90 days more importantly he's got his drive
back it feels like he's 10 years younger so
you want to just know where you stand that would
be number one then there's what what do you do
for peak performance like we work with you know
we have a center for example in pittsburgh we
work with the entire pittsburgh steelers team we
don't just do rehab we do optimization i'm sure
you've heard of david sinclair dr sinclair you're
familiar with him from harvard right so he's one
of the best longevity experts on earth he's a
good friend he's on my board and david is 53
chronologically he's 33 he's younger than you
and i at the level of his organs and how a system
works you can measure it now how do you do it he's
utilized a few things that reawaken your body so
let me give your audience a quick lesson i'm going
to give you three words you don't have to memorize
them they're in the book but the concepts which
you understand so we all know i think by now most
people know your dna is not your destiny those
3.2 billion letters from your mom and 3.2 billion
for your dad make up your genes think of that
as the plan but how you turn out you can have
the same dna and show up different than somebody
else because what matters is your epigenome epi
means above so think of the genome or your dna is
like the piano the piano player is the epigenome
it decides what which genes turn on or off your
epigenome is affected by diet exercise sleep
just about everything you can imagine exposure
to so you want to take care of it well now i'll
give you the three technical words but don't worry
about the technical there are seven master genes
that dr sinclair has discovered that completely
affect the quality of your life and how you age
and the aliveness and strength you have and those
are called sirtuins if you want to know it these
sirtuins have two completely different tasks that
work really well into your late 30s maybe your
early 40s and then they drop off the cliff what
do they do number one they determine which genes
get turned on or off by epigenome it's critical in
terms of your strength your vitality and or your
aging two they reduce inflammation which as i'm
sure you know is the basis of most breakdown and
but three most importantly to me i value energy
so much the energy in your body i'm sure you know
comes from those mitochondria in every cell you
have this little factory that makes it covet gets
in and steals from that that's why people have
that long-term fatigue for example well in order
for those to fire off you need these serotonins
to be doing their job but they have a fuel source
they need you've probably heard of it's called nad
and there's never a d well nad is a fuel source
drops off the cliff late 40s and by early 50s it's
down by at least 50 percent well without the ned
the seratoons can't do the things i told you about
but they also have one other task that just has to
split its focus because it has less fuel it also
these sirtuins go through your body and clean up
your dna so as you get older as you get exposed
you accumulate exposure to etc and your dna
starts to get compromised so the situations go
in and actually heal it repair it but now when
you don't have enough fuel for the sirtuin it's
not enough nad now they have to decide am i going
to clean up dna or am i going to give them enough
energy for the mitochondria and so right when you
need it most because the accumulated challenges
everything starts to break down it's kind of like
if you had a mansion and you were lucky
enough to have this great staff they're young
in the beginning the mansion always looks new
things break down but they get fixed immediately
boom snap your fingers seven billion liver
cells are gone but seven billion new ones come
but as they get older and they get aged they
get tired and then they you don't have the raw
materials your mansion breaks down and that's
aging so remember these master genes that make
all this happen need this fuel source called nad
and nad needs a precursor to be absorbed in the
cells and created and it's the last word i'll give
you it's called nmn many people have heard of it n
is never emma's in mother n well it's dropped off
by 50 now your body starts to break down slowly
but surely or you don't feel the same way you know
you need tremendous energy in the brain that's the
largest source of energy or demand on energy and
all sudden you feel a little foggy and so forth
so good news is it sounds like a terrible
thing oh my god everything starts to break down
you can this natural element in your body slight
problem when i went with david who went with a
lab with him we looked at six different brands
because i was looking which one i want to do
and some are cheap 35 bucks some 125 bucks but no
rhyme or reason none of them had any intent in it
it was advertised and promoted and selling
for it i was like i asked the lab check i
said are these people just cheats he goes well
some do tony most of stuff comes from china
but he said the real problem is it breaks down
within 30 to 45 days so by time somebody gets
it they may not be lying it was in it but it's
gone now and so i said well what's the solution
so david has his own version of mmn but here's
the coolest thing that's coming now evan if you
take an old mouse when i say old mouse like a
70 year old human would be a 20 month old mouse
and you put him on a treadmill the most they can
go without exhaustion is a quarter of a kilometer
but if you give them uh and by the way the
young strong mouse can run four times that much
without exhaustion can go a full kilometer well
watch this they give nmn for 14 days to a mouse
old mouse and within 14 days they're
running two to three kilometers 200 to
300 percent more than the strongest
mouse you go oh that's great tony
do my studies always go with humans the answer
is no not always so that was my first question
so david's in partnership with a group called
eden rock and they have for the last two years
been doing something that's top secret but it just
got released it was in the daily mail and it was
released by a commander who was not supposed
to release it they've been using a new form of
nmn a new molecular crate called mib-626 and this
molecule does not break down like traditional nmn
in fact its absorption level on traditional nmn
the most you get is 30 absorption this one has 300
to 400 more in your body so it's way beyond what
they give the mouse to give you an idea they've
been giving it to the strongest men and women
in the world our special forces for two years
so the commander got so excited even though it's
top secret he talked to somebody in the press
it got reported in boston and then picked up
in the daily mail but they still don't know
most of it i can't tell you i'm an investor
in the company because i want to first access
but i can't tell you things that aren't revealed
but i can tell you what they said what he said was
what you saw in my studies we saw in the strongest
human beings who have less room to grow or improve
he said their endurance levels have exploded more
importantly their strength has increased from
the same level of stimulus and most importantly
their cognitive capacity is shot through the roof
so now there's three different studies one's on it
both long term and short because as i told you it
steals the mitochondria and showing the impact of
this new component there's sums on kidneys because
its long-term impact often affects this and then
there's the traditional ones that they're doing
so they are tracking this with the military and
they believe they'll have approval in 18 to 24
months because it's already gone through safety
and efficacy now it's called efficient scale
so it's not going to be a it'd be something you
go to your doctor for and imagine you could have
a pill that would massively increase the amount
of energy in your body at a mitochondrial level
every cell that means every organ is going to
be operating better the right genes turning
on and off inflammation coming down and your
dna being collected and cleaned up like you're
15 or 18 or 21 years old so those are some of the
things that are exciting so i show you right now
and what's coming not 10 years in the future 12
24 maximum 36 months out so exciting it's so crazy
it's unbelievable last question tony you've done
so much to help so many people for such a long
time if people were to think of you tonight in
their prayers what would you have them pray for
well good health of course that's how i can stick
around but guidance you know continue to guide me
so i can serve as many human beings as possible
i'm privileged to have this amazing life i'm
going to be 62 as i said i look at my life i've
got five kids and five grandkids that i so love
and i'm proud of i got the most amazing wife and i
have the most amazing life where i've been able to
serve literally millions of people because i was
born at a time where i could get on a plane and
go to you know 15 countries in a year and do 125
cities but now i have the technology like being
able to talk with you right now i built the studio
because when they shut down the world and calling
up 10 people i'm used to 15 000. i did a seminar
last week for six straight days for 800 000 people
in 195 countries so i just i want to keep this
health so i can be here for all those i love
and i want to be able to continue to serve so i
appreciate the prayers i believe prayer has power
i love it well the man is tony robbins the book is
life force here's what it looks like go pick it up
we'll link it up in the description below tony as
always man thank you so much thanks for having me
man blessings to you if you want to see the last
time i sat down with tony robbins check the video
right there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you there the
quality of your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on any beautiful children
you have how many people love you the quality
of your life is where you live emotionally this
is the time to retool it's a time for you to say
where's the world now where do i think it's going